thank you
[Music]
are y'all familiar with those little uh
cyborg dogs yeah the ones that like
[ __ ] do backflips spot right the ones
with [ __ ] missiles on their back the
Tamagotchis how the [ __ ] you already
know about the missiles on the back bar
we've been seeing them all over
Instagram
here we go yo why does it gotta look
like the Black Mirror one too oh God
yeah I've seen those videos man yeah
[ __ ] oh he's sleeping oh okay
you look like a little ninja oh my God
why'd he dress him up like a little
ninja
spider yeah that thing's scary dude that
looks exactly like the Black Mirror dog
whoa
blasted in the face
he's not loaded I'd be so nervous why is
it tap dancing that was stupid
look at that tap dancing ass dog
dancing dog
so this is obviously a robot dog with an
RPG strapped to its back that was demoed
recently I recently had a Russian Arms
Fair Russian arms Rush [ __ ] man why they
gotta do it there dude this is this is
what is called the next step in robotic
Warfare no the next step in robotic
Warfare
did you see how uh Russia's gonna start
arming a bunch of countries like selling
their modern weapons to a bunch of
countries good idea
like a bunch I think like countries that
aren't the best is friends with the US
oh yeah wouldn't that be funny if all
those weapons no matter where you shoot
the bullet goes to America oh my God yo
that's really good technology it's like
yeah and it's like wow
oh my God
well that's scary uh little robot dogs
are with with missiles on their back or
is scary for sure are you Loki I'll [ __ ]
with the idea of robotic Warfare like
the idea of like even um I don't think
you know the idea
explains the idea look at your eyebrows
explain the ideas because the idea is
you're like oh you're just gonna let the
robots fight together it's like no
they're using the robots to decimate
human beings over there that's why I
said the idea not the actualization of
robotic Warfare is and making this to
kill humans
just like drones I'm saying the Hugh
Jackman movie where robots [ __ ] fight
BattleBots thank you okay can you just
get a little bit more PG and bring it
back to Toby McGuire okay the point is
the idea of like no longer needing
humans right right in Warfare having
your robots duke it out and then the
best robot wins and then the robots
joined forces because they're like why
are we doing this to each other we're
getting smart ones here turn into a
giant dog they Rebrand to cyberdine yeah
we're the Smart Ones not these [ __ ]
yeah
how does a Russian robot sound like just
like that yeah I believe
that I am a robot I have an accent
my accent was programmed they're like
put vodka into my gas tank
old school giant warfare you got two
countries coming up everybody marches
out and then they're like your Fighter
versus R1 fighter we'll send these
people home to their wives right you
just have a one-on-one bout yeah that
would be cool but imagine this [ __ ]
Hugh Jackman a robot but think about
that sucks to robot Warfare sucks to me
because you're gonna deplete your
country's funds so much quicker it feels
like and all the screws and bolts that's
interesting the idea is to save lives I
don't know I don't think that's the idea
of War well you think about like our
first first generation of like robot
Technologies like drones and then the US
uses that to like blow up Villages you
know that's how we use it we don't blow
people up with drones dude what that's
how it goes down dude they only target
terrorists like they the missiles go
straight and they pass all the questions
accuracy and then it goes straight to
the terrorists and kill one terrorist to
save ten thousand innocence yeah sign me
up come on America we're a good
Christian country
never I get my fried chicken extra
Christian
What If instead of like sending your
best robot to fight it was just like
let's see who has the coolest robot
it's a pageant
dude yeah I got cars yeah the Japanese
are gonna win dude oh [ __ ] yeah a lot of
sex robots right now not sex
but yeah that'd be cool too
[Laughter]
robot patches you want a well-rounded
robot you know you don't want it just
yeah I would ask oh okay realizing that
it was a Japanese sex doll that stopped
World War four
what the [ __ ] I don't think nothing's
ever gonna replace just classic duking
it out man oh they're gonna say sex
I think he's still saying I wonder how
humans violence said I think humans have
to have some type of sacrifice of life
for it to be like oh [ __ ] yeah you win
we're dead because that it'll just be
unlimited [ __ ] War that's true yeah
yeah in that [ __ ] crazy life
like uh outside of human Galactic Empire
type experience it's like
humans dying war is probably good for
our planetary population because it's
reducing the number of humans it's
almost almost like our own version of
natural selection like this natural
selection where it's like I don't know
suddenly a thousand Birds just fall out
of the sky and we're like what the [ __ ]
happened and then there's like human
beings who just like is that natural if
a thousand Birds follow this guy that's
not natural dog that's like something
[ __ ] up man
the robot does RPGs on him to [ __ ]
nuke other humans I'm just that's
natural compared to this I can't
understand what you're saying where we
don't have a natural predator yeah where
almost every other animal has a natural
cutter and that's a lot of us shouldn't
be alive but we're alive you're sounding
very fanless right now guys and I'm all
for it
kids just died like kids like you had a
lot of kids because like half of them
it's not
a lot of people just died back then on a
pogo stick oh
he's gonna get a [ __ ] infection from
playing outside and then [ __ ] have no
legs and [ __ ] somebody's axle on the
wagon's gonna break and then they're
gonna dive like [ __ ] chickenpox yep
from the actual breaking
yeah everybody's heading to Oregon dude
it's coincidental would you guys rather
have like actual cops petroleum the
streets or like these robots
come on man I didn't mean to speed [ __ ]
was [ __ ] up here's what my brain goes
right where it's like the thought
process is yeah let's get robots so
they're not discriminatory right but
then you get like when you see the
stories of Technology not reading black
people's faces because they're like
because of the way they should set up so
then it's like you think like oh even
the robots are gonna be racing oh yeah
they're gonna [ __ ] up there's no winning
the robots like this is natural
selection yeah it's [ __ ] up and the
robots know which races are lesser yeah
right
what do you mean right no I'm sorry
gotcha no no I don't think that
well they did this with an AI bot before
but when when AI was learning off of
human interaction and social interaction
they would eventually pick up hate and
pick up like the on the undertone that
like some some races are less than
others because nine out of ten
programmers are racist right yeah we
just don't want to be part of the first
generation of the RoboCop thing like we
don't we want to be like down the line
they gotta be like bio bio human oh
cyborg cyborgs yeah yeah yeah like
RoboCop racist cops today are just
stronger yep
we need what if the race is against
whites then that's a different kind oh
yeah yeah totally acceptable it might
reverse one day
I don't I don't worry I'm in Hawaii so
I'll be in Hawaii out there yeah don't
worry about it what would you get more
scared of you went into a [ __ ] human
like when you're in war or you want to
tell Robo dog with RPG
who would I be more scared of yeah if
you're just like an infantry the [ __ ]
robot dog yeah yeah cause that
[ __ ] is programmed to do one
thing where if it's like me and like
let's say me and one Russian soldier in
the forest like
come on like it's just us too no one
knows about the fight yeah I know you
don't want to go to war I don't go to
war you got kids I got kids right and
then we could probably just like let's
let's give each other one tonight if I
can have a little Russian barbecue and
then like I won't ride on you you won't
rat on me there's like a Humanity yeah a
[ __ ] robot dog is just like
is that common
comments run into each other on solo
missions that's what I think no and they
and they vote me through like oh
I'm scared I'm scared too yeah I'm so
cool it's very cold here what if two
robot dogs did that oh
[Laughter]
shoot my RPG into your Cannon
Because unless you're like a super Navy
SEAL I think most people are like [ __ ] I
don't want to do this but I have to
fight for my country that's what a lot
of uh the rushing soldiers were doing
they were deserting yeah they're all
those kids were like I thought this was
a military exercise right right I feel
like if they did have robot dogs and
they would just be another specialist
that would be created to like EMP the
[ __ ] out of anything robotic right oh
yeah bro then you just take out your
like [ __ ] robot bone let's go
robot tennis ball strapped up with
[ __ ] dog toys ready for anything
there's a whistle yeah that only robot
dogs
you [ __ ] send a robot cat out so it's
chasing it oh my God that's so dumb
that's the robot mode
I'm saying it's great
foreign
[Music]